hey you know your haters and your
critics that always talk smack about you
where you go telling everybody that's a
hater this is a hater that's a critic
oh all they're doing is hating on me you
know those people they wanted me to
whisper something to you
and here's a thought maybe just
maybe your haters and your critics are
right
what do you mean by that let me explain
to you what i mean by that i've had a
lot of people that tell me pat you're
not good enough you're not going to do
this you're not serious there's no way
in the world all pat talks such a big
game he's going to go do this
all this other stuff i looked at that as
a challenge
and speculation and if i
don't do anything about it those are not
haters
those people were right what they said
about me if i don't go out there and do
it your haters and critics
you don't qualify them as a hater and a
critic
you cannot call them a hater and a
critic the only time you get to call
people haters
and critics is when you don't prove them
wrong
because if you end up doing what they
said you were gonna do they're not
critics and haters
they're just very good at prophesizing
that you were eventually gonna give up
now you may not like this message i'm
giving to you this may be too direct of
a message pat
i don't know why you're telling me this
here right now this is not a way to kick
off my monday
yes it is why because i think too often
uh
we like to criticize haters we like to
criticize critics
we like to just hide behind the idea of
joining all these other memes online and
instagram saying
that person's just a hater that person
is just a critic
no no no no no there are many haters and
critics
that are not haters and critics they're
accurate because you didn't prove them
wrong
so you maybe said pat what do i do about
it
very simple i've had many of them i've
proved wrong
i it's my job you it's your job
if you want to call me a hater and a
critic
it's your job to do whatever you can
to qualify me to be a hater and a critic
by you proving me wrong it's the only
way you'll be able to call me a hater
for the rest of your life
if you actually go out there and do what
you said
you were going to do up until 10 then
you cannot call me a hater on the critic
i know what i'm talking about meaning
your friends and family or whoever that
says you'll never amount to anything
if you don't do anything about it they
were right you are not going to amount
to anything
your job from the moment you're watching
your blood's boiling is it boiling a
little bit
are you thinking about your ex is it
pissing you off are you thinking about
her or him
are you thinking about your cousin what
he said about you or she said about you
you're thinking about that friend of
yours that backstabbed you and went away
and he's been talking behind your
back
are you thinking about that person
visually maybe it's an uncle
are you going are you there right now
did i piss you off a little bit
don't you do something about it go do
something about it
because maybe your ex is right maybe
your cousin is right
maybe your brother your sister your
uncle maybe your teacher is right
maybe you don't want it that bad maybe
all you do is just talk a big game and
act like you really want to win
but you're full of it how about that how
about that does that feel good
that's what your haters and critics
wanted me to whisper to you to tell you
if you don't do anything about it
they're not haters and critics they've
been right all along
until you prove them wrong hopefully
this message is going to do something to
your belly here
maybe a little bit here maybe a little
bit here and hopefully
it's going to get you out of bed
hopefully it's going to get you to go to
the office make your calls
do your follow-up put up the work put in
the work keep your head
down and just focus on what you got to
do and in six months from now 12 months
from now two years three years five
years ten years from now
all those people one they are going to
say you know what i got to tell you
he said he was going to do it he kind of
did it we kind of look like idiots right
now you know what i'm saying we should
have never said that
she said she was going to go do
something big she kind of did it so we
got to kind of stay
quiet yes you do but you got to go
earn that respect from your haters
and critics and qualify them
as haters and critics that's your job
that's not their job
having said that if you enjoyed this
video and you're fired up about it smash
the thumbs up button
and subscribe and if you want to watch
another video with this
it's a video i did in an interview with
a guy from australia where we talked
about the most dangerous enemies to
avoid in life if you want to watch that
video
click over here and go watch that video
and have a great week everybody take
care bye